dernière finition dernier coup de
pinceau après des mois de travail les
bénévoles sont impatients de dévoiler
leur création Guichard dont la plupart
des inédits ça fait quand même trois ans
qui sont pas sortis alors donc
on espérant que le temps soit avec nous
en 2020 l'édition a été annulée pour
cause de tempête et puis il y a eu la
crise sanitaire de mémoire de
carnavalgier il n'y a jamais eu d'arrêt
aussi long depuis la création de
l'événement en 1869 excepté en temps de
guerre
nous avons une grosse interruption au
moment des guerres mondiales 14-18 et
39-45 ensuite la guerre du Golfe 2016
les attentats
nous avons hâte de partager notre
travail laborieux et surtout de faire
voir cette création qui est en attente
depuis trois ans dans nos ateliers avec
beaucoup de restauration par mon équipe
le thème cette année les années 60 les
années rock n' roll avec l'idole des
jeunes ou encore le King l'autre roi du
carnaval c'est ce char toujours en tête
de cortège pierre Rion l'électricien a
décidé de l'animer
là j'installe une peau de la batterie
parce que tout ces sujets fonctionnent
par moteur d'essuie-glace ici c'est la
langue vous voyez
chaque année la petite famille de
bénévoles dispose d'un budget d'environ
30 000 euros pour animer le village
dimanche près de 3000 carnavaliers sont
attendus dans les rues de Manthelan